how i got c-level executives from  billion-dollar companies to get coffee  with me i decided i wanted to know more  rich people like i just i wanted more  rich friends i should say successful  successful friends all my friends are my  age so it's like nobody's crazy  successful or anything i ended up  calling these like major executives i  made a list of like 50 major executives  in milwaukee i said i'm 23 years old i  want to know what it takes to be  successful i'm curious as to what you  have to say i got some no's but i got  more yeses than you'd think i asked the  executives i said what percent of your  success would you say was talent and  what percent of your success would you  say was hard work most of them told me  something along the lines of 30 talent  and 70  hard work the whole thing showed me that  honestly people are so willing to help  you if you ask none of them knew me none  of them had to spend time with me  because i asked they said yes